okay um so this is wildly unlike myself
and a video that you probably haven't
seen me make of this sort before and I
doubt I will make these in the future
hopefully not uh I just have a dog last
night before I went to bed I saw an
article about Megan Tanja is responding
to fat shaming video and I watched the
video from a youtuber named Nicole
Arbour and I was so I was so mad at
first I'm so angry and then I was
immediately just so bummed out and I
couldn't I couldn't stop feeling that
way and I couldn't stop thinking about
it and I couldn't fall asleep and I
literally stayed up all night writing
notes about how the video made me feel
um thinking that if I wrote them down I
would get them out of my system and I
wouldn't want to sit down and do this
right now but I still this morning I
slept for like two hours and then I woke
up and I just feel like I have to say
something about it cuz it sucks so hard
and it's just such a bummer god she's a
comedian and she basically in the video
is sending a message to fat people to
stop being fat and she goes into these
really um just mean ways of explaining
it and that's the only way I can explain
how that video made me feel and Nicole I
don't know you at all but you seem
really smart and you seem like you have
comedic timing I was just bummed that
someone that seemed really smart and
funny would speak about weight that way
um I'm also a comedian I get paid to do
comedy like you do and I was really
triggered by that video
unexpectedly I've had my own issues of
body image in the past some really dark
personal struggles that I have really
really worked on talking first and
foremost and then I've really worked on
myself and moving away from those dark
times and so when you tell someone to
just stop being fat I don't believe that
you're the first person to tell a fat
person to stop being sad I think most
people with body image issues are pretty
self-aware deep down and so what you're
really seeming to say is stop being a
human being stop having emotional issues
stop just stop because it's bothering me
so if you could just stop because I'm
being affected at your pain it it just
becomes a little selfish and mean um and
I don't think you are that person I
don't know to be honest I went on your
Twitter and I looked at your tweets
about it because look I'm all for you
being a contrarian and wanting to start
an alternative conversation and to
engage the audience in discussions that
might lead to really interesting
breakthroughs for people but you
disabled the comments and the likes on
the video and then on your Twitter we're
bragging about gaining a thousand
subscribers in an hour and talking about
how you expected Tyler Oakley to come
for you and you're not scared so it just
it didn't seem like you actually really
cared about the issue that you were
talking about in your video at the end
you're saying that you want to be the
ride-or-die friend for people that are
overweight and be the one to really tell
them like it is but you weren't letting
the people that you are asking to watch
the video have a conversation with you
about it and so to me it looks like
you're using a controversial personal
subject to leverage subscribers
and attention in a really negative way
which really bums me out because comedy
can be amazingly powerful and positive
and I'm not perfect in it but I really
am trying so this is you know more or
less kind of a conversation to myself at
the same time as it's a conversation to
the internet a comedy can be a really
powerful tool and I wish that we could
use it um more respectfully I wish we
could just respect each other as human
beings it's really something I wish and
I guess the more you just kind of say
whatever you want with disregard to
people's feelings the less I I as a
viewer consider you a comedian I just
consider you kind of mean and I don't
want to consider anyone mean I don't
want to be optimistic that everyone can
be an awesome awesome awesome human
being but this video is not just about
you know how I wish you could have
talked about whatever it was you wanted
to talk about a different way this video
is about the people that might have
watched that video and also got
triggered by it to know that hey we're
all just trying to get by we're all
doing life as best we can and that's all
you can do is try to be the best version
of yourself life is a real [ __ ] up
[ __ ] storm of seemingly controllable and
completely uncontrollable moments just
stacked on each other and we're all
trying to make the best of it
so it's really pretentious and
presumptuous to assume that you have the
authority to tell other people what
they're doing wrong so definitively I
guess we all have a responsibility to
ourselves and to the people that we
affect to affect them the best way
possible that's it I guess that's what
this video is about I don't know
I just had to say this stuff because
otherwise I was just gonna walk around
saying it to my dog and we all know that
doesn't make me a better person nor my
dog doesn't make my dog a person period
comedy can get a really bad rap on
YouTube really easily and I'm not even
going to separate like female comedy or
male comedy I think it's all one well
trying to make people laugh but I think
we're smart people we can do better
think deeper challenge yourselves to
have more interesting conversations in a
funny way that's still provoke an
interesting conversation I don't know oh
there we go that's how we end the video
whoo